with just cardboard for cover
iman gave birth to her baby girl 15 days
ago
here under this olive tree all but one
of her six children have been born
during the syrian civil war
she fled here to get away from the
regime shelling and gave birth to her
latest
hours after she arrived
when my children hear any sound they're
frightened what have they done wrong
why should they suffer
they've escaped to idlib the last rebel
outpost in the country
and now the most densely populated
region of syria
packed with civilians who fled the
fighting elsewhere and now have nowhere
else to run to
i've been asked to wear muslim dress to
respect local customs
and everyone tells me they're desperate
for help
they're living out here in a farmers
field
hundreds hundreds of people hundreds of
families
all camped under trees look with just
a few blankets tied up to give them some
shelter
at least three babies at least three
have been born here how much longer they
can continue
they're saying not very much longer at
all
for those pregnant like manal giving
birth here
is a terrifying prospect
everything is so difficult here there's
no water
there's no electricity there are no
toilets no
bathrooms and more than one
echoed hebba's words she gave birth to
her third daughter in the olive grove 12
days ago
but like everyone else here cannot
countenance assyria under complete
control of bashar al-assad
we cannot live under assad he's killed
so many of us
we need to go to turkey or europe if the
turkish one opened the border we will
break it down
and officials hear a warning of another
humanitarian disaster
if the fighting continues
if the bombing and shelling continues
the situation will be catastrophic
we cannot absorb this huge number of
people
three million people have taken shelter
inside idlib city and province
after fleeing attacks elsewhere but the
hts rebel groups
now in control here deemed a terrorist
outfit by the regime who want to crush
it and regain
control of idlib
they say that we're terrorists are these
terrorists
talking about the children
the regime is not fighting jihadists
they're attacking civilians children and
women
they've bombed hospitals mosques even
wells for water where people gather
this is fleeing a sudden surge in air
strikes and fighting
after the breakdown of a ceasefire
brokered by russia and turkey
neighboring turkey is watching this with
mounting concern as more and more people
gather on its border amid growing
demands to let them in
without doing anything we will break the
border wall down and cross to turkey or
europe
[Music]
and that is unlikely to change if the
fighting doesn't stop
and it's the most vulnerable who'll
suffer alex crawford sky news in idlib
syria